les aéroports et les gardes de train
sont bondés en Chine ces jours-ci les
vacances du nouvel an chinois entraîne
chaque année la plus grande migration de
voyageurs sur la planète pas étonnant
dans un pays où vit un sixième de la
population mondiale mais pour la
première fois en 60 ans le nombre de
Chinois est en déclin
fin 2022 nous étions un milliard 410
millions c'est 850 000 personnes de
moins en un an ont annoncé les autorités
première cause de cette diminution la
politique de l'enfant unique qui a été
en vigueur de 1980 à 2015 le
gouvernement chinois permet désormais
d'avoir trois enfants la politique de
l'enfant est vraiment dans le fond à
atrophique la capacité avoir plus la
population chinoise de ce générique ça
c'est une décision gouvernementale il y
a aussi les Chinois qui ont pris la
décision de pas faire un deuxième un
troisième enfant compte tenu que les
frais sociaux pour avoir des enfants
sont très chers en Chine
il donne l'exemple de la garderie qui
peut coûter jusqu'à 8% du salaire annuel
moyen pour un seul enfant
de Pékin à Shanghai l'annonce du déclin
démographique de la Chine n'est pas une
surprise
nous sommes de la génération des enfants
uniques et devons nous occuper de nos
quatre parents agés 17 mers le
gouvernement a bon nous encourager à
avoir trois enfants on ne peut pas se le
permettre qui
ose avoir des enfants demande cette
autre jeune le taux de chômage est élevé
et la covid a tout détruit il n'y a rien
à faire et ce serait le début d'un long
déclin même que les démographes les plus
pessimistes voient la Chine avec
seulement 600 millions d'habitants au
tournant du prochain siècle on va perdre
800 millions de personnes en l'espace
d'ici 2100 c'est un homme alors tout ce
qui est construit depuis plusieurs
années c'est à dire les tours les
infrastructures je veux dire ils vont se
vider
on monte l'âge de la retraite à
l'échelle de la Chine et qu'on n'aura
pas nécessairement les moyens
d'entretenir une population de 400
millions de personnes âgées et que les
jeunes ne pourront pas payer pour ça
qu'est-ce qui va arriver le gouvernement
va devoir débourser les finances
publiques en Chine sont extrêmement
endettés
et pas tout aussi à l'international
l'époque d'une main d'oeuvre chinoise
disponible et bon marché finira par être
révolue dès cette année la population
indienne plus jeune dépassera la Chine
l'Inde et de plus en plus attirante pour
les investisseurs historiquement la
chaîne a beaucoup utilisé son
pro-démographie pour faire un peu la loi
en Asie et là maintenant elle a un
adversaire de travail et même de grande
taille c'est l'Inde donc ça le va avoir
un effet sur le psychie dans le fond
d'une nationalisme chinois l'économie et
la géopolitique mondiale tranquillement
sont appelés à changer ici
jean-Sébastien Cloutier Radio-Canada